let's go to our caller from the five one
two area code who's calling today from
five one two hello
yeah that's you all right good
how's it going Pakman goodness Enzo
Lorenzo you said uh Enzo yeah from
Southern California
Enzo okay what's going on yeah so I've
been going around your sub right I've
been seeing a lot of the commentary that
people are saying about the primary race
so a little different from the whole
covert scandal that's happening yep
but something I wanted to ask about that
people seem to be freaking out is on the
issue of Supreme Court justices there
seems to be this notion I guess from a
lot of progressive people that Biden is
going to cues a center right you're a
centrist jerk instead of choosing
someone from the left do you think that
fears anyway I guess apparent I mean
listen Biden is certainly going to
choose someone more to the center than
somebody like Bernie Sanders would be
likely to select but you know to say
Biden will choose a right-wing judge
I've not seen anything but evidentiary
that would suggest that and again I
think the real question is who would
Trump pick versus who would Biden pick
but no I would assume Biden would pick
someone who's center-left but certainly
not far left that that would be my best
guess as to who Biden would select I
guess as a follow-up to that do you
think it's better that someone would
choose a far left justice because we
always see on like the Republican side
from like all the bushes and even Trump
now you're always accusing guy yes like
far-right judges there do you think it
would be fair for the Democrats to try
to at least put someone back that would
be I guess progressive for like 20 more
years and all standards I actually have
a different take on that question there
really aren't that many quote far left
justices that would be likely candidates
for the Supreme Court I mean like today
who who's I don't know who is considered
to be furthest left on the Supreme Court
I'm sure there is someone but I don't
know if it's like Sotomayor or Kagan or
you know our Ruth Bader Ginsburg or
whatever but there's nobody that's very
far left on the court right now I mean
occasion you know you have you have a
certainly it's it's a range that I
believe goes from pretty far right to
center left as it is and the uu the
point that I think you're making that's
the really good one is are there even
any truly far left people that someone
like Bernie would even be likely to
select because the slate of folks likely
to be chosen from is going to be people
that are sort of nominally left people
in the kind of Obama Clinton Biden era
and a little bit left than that so I
also think it's important to manage
expectations about what we mean by a
super left Supreme Court justice anyway
I don't think it's that likely because I
don't think there are that many
candidates that would be likely to be
seriously considered yeah absolutely I
think you know we're thinking on the
same level here about the whole justice
issue so that's what these thoughts I
had about who Biden would pick and like
some of the issues about that yep I
think it would be a center-left person
and they would probably be slightly more
centrist than who someone like Bernie
would end up with and that that that's
where I see it thank you for the call
very much appreciate hearing from you
hope to hear from you again